real good it's about to get real yell
and you know what's up because I say
this feel up this is where they
announced they're like big city skyline
I'm definite balanced letter n PS boy
good probably is that looks like yet
until you ditched in tennis at 36 and
park repeat guys be advised yeah yeah
whatever
come on cool [ __ ] yeah that is been what
fake there you go
I should
[Music]
can be severed and clear since they were
going to have your leaflet come here
that's what do you eat why the rest boss
looks a bit like the demons are moving
in on fixed territory one play will get
the weapons zipping from the amazing
game and the look at the self down whoa
oh my god this is just amazing
spider-man 2 but bad blow is good
drastic you don't know [ __ ] about
nothing boy yeah say you did that there
too although it looks pretty it for sure
no no it's just the gameplay looks
exactly like something I already saw and
it wasn't bad games like that was pretty
cool
ok he's gonna have like spider-man
homecoming cool web shooters I heard
that's why the UI go I remember that
they showed him the original trailer
remember I knew that was going to be a
Western I knew it was going to be a
whether to like you think you told me
wasn't gonna be gameplay and I said yes
it's going to be game pledging for no I
said that far to us - damn this
territory dollars now that's a negative
you actually suck sure there's fiber on
them if you have multi loser all of
spider singing okay combat let's prepare
Oh looks like our new ticket yeah look a
lot like an even like more fluent and we
didn't request right this is exactly
what I was talking about in the
retrospective work it needs to not be
counter dodged it any couldn't be dodged
we're used spider-sense to get out of
the way but not the directly counter
don't rip off Arkham get us sued the
spider-man to stay not good I didn't go
along but is exactly what I was asking
for
[Music]
hey Willie this jumpsuit slimming wait
the demon who's their leader one mental
London maybe I'll jump
and it was
what camera angle is the kingpin holding
that bird trooper that's half the middle
they just bad guys from other bad guys
not how I thought today would go like
[Music]
look it's giving me some are even some
estimations going on about how they
don't stay long
let's AC is about a soul
and here we got a guide in that trailer
yes
oh that's cool I like the way the camera
lock I'm so glad websites are a thing
again not quite a [ __ ]
it's the amazing skirt the carriage is
the best bet that's really cool I feel
happy then okay he looks a little bit
like spider-man 3 they look better
well this your men are stick wonderingly
times you can really believe with which
one you're going to find those are you
check the roof I have real helpful
they're fit we'll all right
this level design is giving you three -
dimensions lies - mr. negative yeah
I'm just you know doing the whole thing
show us more face when we doing next
oh cool today is all right I like the
custom on everyone's but he's okay I
mean you never know with Pinellas cool
is that he has two different personality
like this negative normal diet again
he's a super nice guy and tried actively
to stop himself from that stuff we have
that much friction again David their
strength and then there's the a sticky
beat but you're going to knock on wall
it run alone he can loving lips
skyscraper I can show you three is no
hassles that's really dumb he's marble
here and over here what he's up
certainly far your so brother is also
super cool and it maybe you don't suck
that bad okay well Ryan close though
he's alright because they're well
animated needle they don't take you out
of gameplay for no reason
oh yeah those swinging around yeah this
disturbance okay already I'm so on board
because look how much of a pendulum you
look like there's so much it if you look
it's always love it hurt them but I feel
like they would wait back
complicated it's not urine I got them
spike is the voice actor David Gary
spits on ice Roger saw on board for
mayor what those bodies I know I know
maybe you super hero a little faster
working on hearing with this wing it
looks like it has physics to it in full
makeup and I was the gentleman animate I
know I'm really live through at the same
speed
this looks like spider-man 2 web
slinging dischargeable environment like
are you on that corner of dangle school
I like that there's less desperate for
your shop or wall now let go quick the
eyes are opening and closing like
there's actual eyes like it makes it
like it because it makes up yeah there's
the part or there's the part for stuff
you're doing from the internet so it's
done you can lie down to these things
that make the perfect room to play and
you just did lie a certain button and
walk forward yeah so it's it's alter
good this is the flight to Newark I feel
like I've heard that with before program
probably mammoths why are you doing this
oh my god it looks just like been worse
no x-men origins Wolverine has this
exactly
[Music]
why
Oh started it's uncharted type your
character about song - I like no no I'm
saying I like it
I'm not bashing on vanilla that so much
it was hard if your character with with
[ __ ] fireman is perfect oh yeah
[Music]
clearly the entire budget went into
animating the web that's an important
thing to animate okay when it's like
amazing spider-man 2 really like a train
you know I'm saying that because it
looks fluid it's sort of weird intended
yes of Martin Lee I think the guys name
is that he actually likes runs a
homeless shelter in Salinas I like doing
- thanks
that the tire company hit more let's go
wait Oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]